I know that a lot of crazy things have
been normalized during the Trump era but
what is in John Bolton's book is blowing
everything else out of the water I I
don't know how else to say it now that
we've talked about the bogus attempts to
suppress the release of John Bolton's
book I want to talk about what is
actually in the book and it is I mean
listen I don't want to be hyperbolic but
the sum total of what Bolton alleges in
this book essentially blows every other
Trump scandal out of the water and as
usual if only 5% of what Bolton says in
the book is true it's worse than we ever
imagined that's that's the sort of math
of it now let's get right into the
insanity John Bolton asserts in his book
that in 2019 at the g20 Chinese
President Xi explained to Donald Trump
that he is essentially building
concentration camps to imprison this
Muslim population in China the yogurts
and according to the interpreter present
for that conversation Donald Trump said
to the Chinese president that the camps
should be built and that it is the right
thing to do Donald Trump allegedly
okayed concentration camps for China's
Muslim population in a conversation with
the Chinese President according to John
Bolton this was not an isolated incident
Bolton claims in his book that the top
Asia staffer for the National Security
Council Matthew Pottenger told him that
in 2017 Trump said the exact same thing
about the concentration camp camp for
the you gers are we Gers I'm not exactly
sure the the preferred pronunciation
there this is obviously a completely
unconscionable thing for Donald Trump to
say but what's bonkers is that this is
only the tip of the iceberg with John
Bolton's book Boulton claims that on
multiple occasions Donald Trump said he
was willing to help end criminal
investigations into major companies in
China and Turkey as favors to presidents
XI and odo on Bolton alleges that Trump
privately told him that reporter
deserve prison and in some cases should
be executed because they are quote
scumbags the allegation is that the
President of the United States said
reporters members of the media should be
either imprisoned or executed for their
reporting john bolton alleges that
donald trump lacked just basic foreign
policy knowledge like as an example
bolton says Trump didn't know that the
United Kingdom has nuclear weapons
Donald Trump reportedly asked whether
Finland is part of Russia Donald Trump
reportedly said it would be cool to
invade Venezuela Bolton recalled that
White House chief of staff John Kelly
told that story according to the book
during Trump's 2018 meeting with the
North Korean dictator Kim jong-un
Trump's own Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo slipped a note to Bolton saying
Trump is full of s months later
Pompeyo allegedly dismissed trumps
entire North Korea gambit as having a
quote zero probability of success
meanwhile Pompeo publicly was saying
Trump's doing a great job
on North Korea there's an entire
additional set of claims in Bolton's
book that has to do with Donald Trump
asking the Chinese president to help him
win in 2020 now this is particularly
stunning because you might remember we
covered this when it happened George
Stephanopoulos from ABC actually
interviewed Donald Trump and asked him
would you call the FBI if Russia tried
to help you in 2020 if China tried to
help you and Trump said well I might but
I also might look at the information I
might accept them remember this clip
this is somebody that said we have
information on your opponent oh let me
call the FBI give me a break
life doesn't work our director says
that's what should happen the FBI
director is wrong your campaign this
time around a foreigners if Russia if
China if someone else offers you
information on opponents should they
accept it or should they call the FBI I
think maybe you do both I think you
might want to listen I don't there's
nothing wrong with listening if somebody
called from a country Norway we have
information on your opponent
oh I think I'd want to hear you want
that kind of interference in our
elections it's not an interference they
have information I think I'd take it if
I thought there was something wrong I'd
go maybe to the FBI if I thought there
was something wrong but when somebody
comes up with a poor research right they
come up with a poor research oh let's
call the FBI the FBI doesn't have enough
agents to take care of it but you go and
talk honestly to congressmen they all do
it they always have and that's the way
it is
it's called Oppo research well it turns
out that this was not merely theoretical
for Donald Trump Trump actually went to
the Chinese president according to
Bolton and asked for help and the way
Trump asked President Xi for help was to
explain listen President Xi farmers are
really important to my re-election in
2020 I need you to help me get reelected
by making larger purchases of soybeans
and wheat from the United States farmers
so this is not just Trump accepting
information this is not just Trump
accepting help this is Trump asking for
help to get reelected lastly for today
on the claims in the book and we
couldn't possibly cover everything
that's in the book Boulton says that
Donald Trump regularly made it clear
that there was an obvious and overt quid
pro quo with Ukraine Bolton says Trump
would regularly say don't send any aid
to Ukraine until we get the materials
about Hillary Clinton and Joe Biden so
again we're going to talk more about
John Bolton being a trader in a little
bit you don't have to believe John
Bolton is a good person because he's not
you don't have to excuse John Bolton's
sick role as an architect of the Iraq
war to realize that if even 5% of what
he says in the book is true this is the
most insane story or set of allegations
about Donald Trump from the beginning
John Bolton has done many bad things but
Bolton I don't believe is just going to
make up all of this stuff out of thin
air when you realize that nothing that
Bolton claims is out of character with
Trump that also is part of the picture
here now why didn't John Bolton say it
seven months ago
why didn't John Bolton show up and say
it in front of the House impeachment
committee Bolton should have told us
sooner and he's even sicker because of
the fact that he didn't
we are going to get to that later on in
the program he is not going to be
excused for for that but the claims are
absolutely and completely stunning and
the fact that Bolton waited to do it in
a book is pathetic and it's just part of
Bolton's worldview which big picture I
completely disagree with let me know
your reaction to the assertions on
Twitter I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and
later we will talk about how we should
judge Bolton for how he decided to do
all of this